what does that do I think they're  cleaning out the name it doesn't that  put him at risk no I think you can't the  whistleblower statutes being abused and  I got to run in here it designed to  protect you from being fired if you come  forward it doesn't give you an anemone  nobody should be prosecuted based on an  anonymous accusation impeachment is the  political death penalty without the  whistleblower complaint none of this  would be going on so I want to know who  the person is but the people who should  do this are the Intel committee in the  Senate they're the ones that were  assigned this case I think it's  impossible to go forward without knowing  who the whistleblower is and giving the  president a chance to cross-examine his  accuser  you